sélectionnez déjà votre texte
sélectionnez un texte le mettre en forme
ce matin la maison digital se tient un
atelier de traitement texte dit saint
quentinois sont allés coûte leur point
commun lemondenumerique l'aurait plutôt
inconnu je voulais apprendre plus je
sais pas grande chose mais je voulais je
voulais découvrir à quoi ça va vous
servir de console sur les cds sur
rechercher un travail sur
sur par exemple
si je prends le métro elles sont les
premières bénéficiaires d'un programme
lancé en juin par la cité des métiers de
saint quentin en yvelines et
l'association alpha bus et des ateliers
ce sont des ateliers pour la découverte
de l'ordinateur tout ce qui est
découverte
de la boîte mail
naviguer sur internet word et excel et
aussi tout ce qui est des marchands
livre on est aussi maintenant un atelier
sur la morbidité
ensemble avec elle s'inscrit dans le
cadre de la maison digital projets
accompagnés par la fondation orange
permettre à des femmes plutôt en
situation de précarité
de s'élever socialement
professionnellement et le sérieux aussi
la cité des métiers ça faisait un
certain temps qu'il travaillait avec des
avec des femmes en difficultés et les
bilans étaient plus que positif la
fondation orange a aussi aidé à
renouveler le parc numérique de la cité
les ateliers sont animés par des membres
de l'association orange solidarité la
cité des métiers espère accompagner une
quarantaine de femmes sur cette année